[Music]
Serena Williams and her daughter Olympia
Ohanian are mommy daughter goals thanks
to a little nudge from Olympia to get
her mom in on the fun so that was really
fun
the tennis pro shared this clip of her
little girl rocking out to lukala's
pretty girl era in front of paris's
Eiffel Tower but after just a few
moments the five-year-old ditches her
solo act and pulls her mama into frame
for a duet
[Music]
that's Arena who is currently expecting
baby number two with her hubby Alexis
Ohanian serving up her best Tick-Tock
moves the most rewarding thing is just
seeing her smile every day it makes me
so happy in the caption Serena jokes
that she doesn't have the tick tock
dances down just yet but soon I like to
actually be the best at whatever I do
dancing you can't beat it then throw the
Eiffel Tower in front of the Sim
hmm fun times even though you know it
was a little bit tired but you know we
gotta kind of hang in there
[Music]
of course Serena debuted her baby bump
at the 2023 Met Gala in May breaking the
news of baby number two on Instagram
just before hitting the carpet thanking
Anna Wintour for inviting her her hubby
and their baby to be to Fashion's
biggest night y'all congratulations as
for Olympia she learned she was going to
be a big sis just moments before the
rest of the world so the big reveal will
be at the Met and then before we leave
I'll tell Olympia the reason I haven't
told her is because she can't keep a
secret yeah it's definitely not easy and
when they finally shared the news with
their little girl she was over the moon
remember how you've been praying for a
little sister or brother
well I we went to the doctor
and it turns out I have a baby
are you kidding me no you're gonna be a
big sister
okay
and it's safe to say Serena is just as
excited I've always wanted to be a mom
you know but I never seem to have time I
was always working with my career and
then Dove right in and it's so natural
for me and
um I love it I love her so much and you
know it's we have a great little family
going on back in 2018 Serena opened up
to ET about balancing motherhood and her
career working method is real it's so
real but I have my priorities in Olympia
is that I'm never a day without Olympia
like she's my priority and every day I
like need to be home with her because I
don't I don't want to miss any moments
with her Flash Forward to last year so
Arena announced she's stepping away from
the court for now as her dream of
expanding her family comes true
foreign
[Music]
thank you